[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt am
10 mai ist muttertag und auch der
geburtstag meiner mama deswegen möchte
ich heute kleine törtchen machen und
muttertag weil es ja im mai es ist für
mich immer was mit erdbeere ich verbinde
immer erdball mit motor tag also geht's
heute kleine erdbeertörtchen die werden
dann später mit new york place überzogen
und ihr könnt sie wirklich super
vorbereiten da man die törtchen vorher
gut einfrieren kann also können sie auch
gerne schon ein zwei tage vorher bereit
machen und dann einfach am muttertag
dann fertig dekorieren fertig und dann
habt ihr so kleine törtchen die können
dann an die mama und an die
schwiegermama verschränken also richtig
ein richtig tolles rezept zum teilen und
ich mache jetzt zuerst einmal einen
kuchenteig und zwar einen red velvet
kuchenteig red velvet heißt einfach
roter samt weil damals dieser kuchen
gemacht wurde mit kakao und es wird
einfach ein bisschen säure dazu gegeben
essig oder eben buttermilch und dadurch
hat sich der kakao verfärbt in rot und
deswegen hieß daneben der kuchen so ich
helfe heute aber auch noch ein bisschen
mit roter farbe passt danach sagen wir
wirklich schönes sattes rot also für den
teil des im rührteig verwende ich 100
gramm weiche butter 100 gramm zucker
eine prise salz und etwas vanille
extrakt habe ich noch etwas rote fasste
zwei eier die sind schon zimmer waren
150 gramm mehl jeweils einen teelöffel
kakao und backpulver einen esslöffel
essig dann nehme ich jetzt eine frucht
essig und 75 gramm warme milch nämlich
zuerst die weiche butter und verrühren
sie dann mit dem salz und zucker richtig
schön cremig daraus etwa vier bis fünf
minuten
das wird jetzt ein muttertags rezept
am 10 wenn oma geburtstag hat oma hat
geburtstag und muttertag wenn die butter
zucker maße dann so weit ist dann die
eier einzeln dazu geben wir eins nach
dem anderen
das war jetzt habe ich eine fleißige
küchenhilfe hier jetzt kann ich wieder
stärker machen
für mich ist jeder tag muttertag weil er
mir immer viel hält nun immer für mich
praktisch und will damals gemüse
sich die helfen machst du rein schützen
kann ruhig mitarbeiter
und dann gleich die schlüssel ins
waschbecken das steak
und jetzt kommt schon mal die farbe dazu
und unternehmen wir verpasste weil die
einfach super intensiv ist perfekt das
reicht schon so
hier kann ich jetzt schon mal backpulver
ich dachte es schneit sind die blüten am
baum ich dachte es schneit
die weißen blüten fallen gerade vom baum
und es sieht echt aus dem schnee jetzt
kann ich hier schon mal mehl backpulver
und kaufen mission
ich glaube hier sieben es auch kurz
damit es keine klümpchen gibt
[Musik]
jetzt hier ein 47 doch dann endlich
gesetzlich dazu und die milch die
mindest die darf auch gerne warm sein
jetzt ganz kurz verrühren ihr könnt den
es sich auch weglassen wenn ihr jetzt
zum beispiel butter menschen nehmen da
ist dann schon säure drin oder auch
nicht nur zitronensaft
und jetzt nur noch ganz kurz hören
willst du beide ist natürlich den teig
geben meine backform ich nehme jetzt
hier einfach mein backblech mit dem bug
rahmen drum und habe den auf 25 x 25 cm
eingestellt ich bin nämlich jetzt nur
eine ganz dünne teigplatten nicht sehr
kurz war teil
und dann kann die teigplatten backofen
ohne der zwischenzeit kann ich mich
schon mal um die creme kümmern
ich glaube damit die teigplatten richtig
dünn wird sie ist auch auseinander und
macht 30 mal 30
[Musik]
und zwar witzig denn ich hatte den
gleichen zitronenkuchen auch damals im
gleichen alter gemacht hatte auch einmal
backpulver vergessen hatten wir auch die
zitronen kekse stadtzentrum kuchen aber
nicht schlimm es war trotzdem voll
lecker
[Musik]
der kuchen ist jetzt gebacken und ich
habe ihn auch schon abkühlen lassen also
sieht da ausländer fertig ist den stell
dich jetzt kurz zur seite und kann mich
jetzt schon mal um die erdbeer muss
kümmern
für die etwa muss könnte jetzt entweder
frische erdbeeren benutzen oder auch
gefrorene ich nehme da auch immer ganz
gern gefrorene apple denn die werden
ganz reif geerntet und dann sofort
eingefroren und haben wirklich den
vollen geschmack
dafür brauche ich also 250 gramm
erdbeeren frisch oder tiefgefroren einen
teelöffel zitronensaft 120 gramm
magerquark 30 gramm puderzucker etwas
vanille extrakt 11 gramm gemahlene
gelatine 70 gramm sahne und 200 wagen
das könnt ihr zuerst die kleine menge
seiner nehmen und mit der gelatine
verrühren und geht dann kurz quellen
lassen und hier nehme ich jetzt statine
weil nämlich ganz das ganze wie so eine
mousse wird also so eine mousse textur
haben ihr könnt doch aka aka benutzen
also pflanzliches geliermittel dann habt
ihr einfach keine gelatine mit dabei
aber kaká ist ein bisschen festsaal das
bindet viel fester wenn euch das nicht
stört nehmen wir einfach gaga beachtet
da aber dass ihr dann nicht nochmals
alle braucht um das akw was quellen zu
lassen sondern ihr könnt dann das acker
direkt mit der gleichen menge wasser
also hier 70 gramm einfach zu den
erdbeeren dazu geben damit pürieren und
dann aufkochen lassen also dass er wird
die zubereitung bisschen anders wie
gesagt ist es nur eine geschmackssache
also eine textur sache und ich will eben
dass es schön weich und muss artig wird
daher nehme ich jetzt relativismus jetzt
hier und ein bisschen quellen etwa zehn
minuten
in der zwischenzeit kann ich jetzt hier
schon mal die erdbahn pürieren das sieht
aus wie ein trauriger smiley
weil ich es meine
jetzt hier einfach ein bisschen zitronen
uns auftreiben geben und pürieren rang
geschafft
ich habe übrigens auf trauen lassen
mehr darf es schon mal einen top
einfüllen gerne schön aus katzen und das
erwarte ich jetzt gleich auf kochen muss
ich jetzt im prinzip nicht aber ich
lasse es ist trotzdem ganz kurz
aufkochen
so etwa eine halbe minute bis minuten
köcheln lassen du kannst du schon mal
rühren und ich kann in der zwischenzeit
hier schon mal den quark vermögen also
den quark berühren mit etwas puderzucker
und vanille extrakt vanille passt
nämlich perfekt zu erdbeeren
und wenn ihr dann den quax at habt könnt
ihr auch noch die sahne steif schlagen
die sahne ist jetzt steigt die stelle
ich ganz kurz in den kühlschrank
denn ich muss jetzt ganz kurz noch auf
die gelatine warten die es noch nicht
ganz so weit
und da geht es gleich weiter auf jeden
fall die etwa masse warmhalten nicht
abkühlen lassen denn die show maschine
wird da gleich tränen aufgelöst jetzt
kannst du hier schon mal den teig lösen
und zwar erstens backpapier unterwegs
und dann so wegrollen und den teig
rahmen lösen und ich kann jetzt hier
schon mal die gelatine dieses schön
gequollen wie man sieht ganz fest
geworden
und die kommt jetzt hier in die erdmasse
rein dies ja noch warm und da wirklich
darauf achten dass relative niemals
gekocht werden darf ganz anders als
agrar- oder magazine
sonst verliert sie nämlich ihre binde
eigenschaft also nur in warmen dingen
auflösen
so brauchen wir den auch ganz schön
das habe ich also hier diese vier
bestandteile einmal den kuchen die sahne
den quark und die erste masse und jetzt
bereitet ihr am besten schon eure form
vor
ich packe ich gerne in silikon förmchen
aber ich nehme sie ganz gerne um kuchen
und krems in form zu bringen
und gerade bei merkels ist es wirklich
super wichtig dass sie außen eine
perfekt gerade fläche und eine glatte
fläche habt unter eignen sich silikon
förmchen echt gut wir nehmen jetzt hier
diese kleinen herzchen den dt korea
später als erdbeeren ok und damit auch
nicht so ein großes volumen also ein
kleines örtchen ist dann echt perfekt
zum verschenken
jetzt gebe ich moment jetzt muss ich
schnell arbeiten so mehr wegen der
gelatine
es gebe ich hier ein paar esslöffel der
quarkmasse hinein um einfach die
gelatine an die temperatur anzufassen
und jetzt hier zurück in den großen topf
also später wenn es gefahren ist ja das
ist ja nicht die mir okay ist das wird
jetzt die erdbeer moos und die majors
kommt später drauf jetzt die sahne kurz
unterheben
hier mache ich auch immer gerne eine
muss bei den everest örtchen weil ich
die jetzt schön eingießen kann und
dadurch wird es eben auch schon glatt
später dann in die firmen müssen und
nicht ganz voll denn gleich kommt ja
noch der torten deckel drauf bestimmt
ich fühle mich besser einfühlen
[Musik]
es ist auch so schwer
ein bisschen was aber noch übrig am
besten setzt ihr euch das förmchen
vorher schon auf eine unterlage
ich denke doch nur jedes mal stand ich
kurz glaubt perfekt sieht schon richtig
gut aus ich glaube 12 treppchen kann ich
hier noch rein geben und dann gleich
würde ich erfüllen den restlichen
anderes förmchen ein dass man noch mehr
törtchen und jetzt nehmt ihr euch nun
ausstecher der zu eurer form passt denn
ich möchte jetzt den kuchen hier als
boden so zu sagen haben
ich denke das könnte passen
wir probieren es auch einen kleinen
kuchen machen ist irgendwo so dürfte es
sein aber das macht gar nichts denn ihr
müsst jetzt darauf achten dass die form
glatt ab ist also den kuchen einfach
leicht eindrücken gerne noch mal mit ein
paar tröpfchen auffüllen
so ist perfekt schön gerade verstanden
du standest aus ich jetzt einfach so
dass es hier schön glatt abschließt
gemacht
[Musik]
das kommt jetzt so in den gefrierschrank
damit die törtchen einstellen können
denn wenn wir da ein allgemeines
drüberziehen muss der untergrund schön
gefroren sein damit die merckle ist
schön drauf haften bleibt und eben auch
im wunderschönen glatt wird aus dem rest
mache ich jetzt wahrscheinlich einfach
noch die anderen kleinen förmchen aber
ihr könnt doch aus dem rest einfach
kleine löffel desserts machen die
törtchen sind jetzt eingefroren ich habe
es einfach über nacht ins gefrierfach
gestellt aber es reichen da wirklich
auch vier bis fünf stunden bis sie
komplett gefroren sind jetzt kommt der
oakley sich drüber entweder macht ihr
jetzt mein grundrezept und macht die
merckle ist einfach komplett selbst auch
mal ein paar zutaten dafür aber man kann
es wirklich super zu bereiten oder er
verwendet so wie ich jetzt weil es
einfach schneller geht und einfacher
geht dem rock days hier und hier brauche
ich jetzt einfach nur ein päckchen
merkels dann nehme ich jetzt rosa dies
von küche und 400 kam milch und ich
nehme da noch etwas rote verpasste denn
ich möchte eine rote meer glas damit die
törtchen eben auch wie eine erdbeere
aussehen
ich werde zuerst einmal hier die milch
in den topf geben und ganz kurz
aufkochen lassen
[Musik]
jetzt könnt ihr hier also die milch habe
ich jetzt wieder runtergezogen
jetzt könnt ihr hier die workplace
klümpchen frei einrühren
das rosa welt schon perfekt und die
herzchen zu überziehen aber dadurch dass
es erdbeeren werden sollen gebe ich noch
ein bisschen rote verpasste dazu damit
einfach ein schönes sattes rot wird und
jetzt ist auch gleich ganz wichtig dass
dem irak lace up kühlt auf etwa 35 grad
also etwa hand wärme und damit kann ich
dann die gefroren und törtchen
überziehen also während die jetzt hier
abkühlt wie stößt dennoch immer wieder
durch kann ich schon mal die törtchen
aus dem silikon formen rausnehmen also
einfach raus stürzen auf dem gitter
schon mal stellen solange aber nochmal
einfrieren und gleich daneben überziehen
mit der name
hier löse ich jetzt die törtchen einfach
silikon rand zuerst das okay so schön
glatt raus stürzen
wenn ich die workplace komplett selbst
machen möchte dann gebt ihr glukosesirup
mit zucker und wasser in einen topf und
last so lange kochen bis sie 105 grad
erreicht habt also da muss man auf jeden
fall mit thermometer arbeiten
anschließend kommt kondensmilch dazu und
zwar die gesüßte kondensmilch also die
etwas dickere da braucht man dann schon
so ein paar spezielle zutaten grad der
glukose sirup ist da eben superwichtig
dann etwas gequält
latina als ehemaliger latino vorher
einweichen lassen
die braucht man natürlich zum wenden und
auch immer darauf achten dass gelatine
nicht kommen darf
auch diese mary chase die können wir
natürlich auch aufbewahren wenn etwas
übrig habt und später noch mal in der
mikrowelle zum beispiel erwärmen aber
eben nicht kochen lassen und weiße
schokolade und dann fehlt hier nur noch
die farbe die könnt ihr dann eben auch
als lebensmittel verpasste dazugeben und
dann habt ihr die selbst hergestellte
mir oakley wie gesagt dass ein bisschen
aufwendiger vor allem mit den speziellen
zutaten die man braucht und auf jeden
fall sollte man beim thermometer
arbeiten
damit die workplace jetzt keine
luftbläschen hat könnt ihr jetzt gerne
noch sieben also durch ein ganz feines
sieb gießen am besten mit einem trichter
dann auch direkt in ein gefäß mit jetzt
auch nicht zu lange warten also ist es
darf jetzt auch nicht zu kalt werden
falls sie doch mal zu kalt geworden ist
können dass sie im wasserbad wie gesagt
noch mal erwerben
man schließt jetzt hier ganz langsam
durch fließen und so entferne ich jetzt
alle luft blasen
und jetzt einfach über die gefrorenen
törtchen darüber gießen eine
auffangschale unterlegen denn ihr könnte
die neue regel ist einfach nochmal
erwärmen und weiter benutzen
ich habe jetzt euch mal vier herzchen
mit der selbstgemachten merkels
überzogen und vier mit der küche merkels
und was richtig gut auf fällt also die
die ich gemacht habe diesen bisschen
dünn also direkt nicht ganz so gut ich
glaube ich jetzt einfach ein bisschen
stehen lassen müssen wahrscheinlich
und vielleicht bisschen mehr farbe rein
geben müssen und die hier die habe ich
jetzt hier mit der küche mir angst
gemacht dies wirklich schön decken
das jetzt noch wie schöne erdbeeren
aussieht nämlich bisschen sesam für die
oberfläche macht es hier so kleine
erdball körnchen rein
der perfektionist wird sie jetzt mit der
pinzette draufsetzen
damit alle in eine richtung gucken
nein das mache ich heute nicht
die taschen sind jetzt fast fertig aber
natürlich fehlt auch das grün der
erdbeere
deswegen habe ich es hier etwas grünen
fondant den verknetet geraten und mit
etwas cnc also zellulose pulver ihr
könnt doch einfach blüten war es damit
ein kneten damit er von dort einfach ein
bisschen aushärten kann ihr könnt auch
marzipan nehmen stattdessen wenn ihr das
lecker findet also einfach so ein
bisschen was zu modellieren
jetzt kann ich jedem fondant dünn
ausrollen und daraus als kleine blätter
ausstechen
ich habe es keine erdbeeren blatter
ausstechen arbeitnehmer einfach so was
ähnliches
ich habe es ja immer so ein stern
förmiges platz und so ein strukturiertes
blatt das kann ich jetzt hier ausstechen
und wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr dann noch
etwas pulver farbe nehmen einfach zum
sortieren das muss aber nicht sein und
ich stich thema aus und stand dann rein
dann habt ihr nämlich schön diese
struktur mit dabei
mit pulver farben kriegt man da halt
einfach mal so ein bisschen das ganze
realistisch wenn also sieht uns schon
immer noch einen ticken besser aus und
gefällt es dir da kommen jetzt noch die
grünen teile dran und dann ja fast
zeitgleich kollege oder ja genau die
kundschaft lacht ich zeige euch jetzt
mal anhand eines örtchens wie es jetzt
fertiggestellt wird
ich nehme hier passend zum werk des
täters mertes geschirr und sucht jetzt
eine erste aus ich kenne ja als
abgestimmt wie hängen diese fielen
runter man muss ja auch immer gut
abtropfen lassen
jetzt sieht man ja auch schon dass die
klose fest wird jetzt kann man es
praktisch
ich glaube ich nämlich sogar zwei
übereinander damit ich die vorder und
die rückseite habe die klebe ich dann
dort daran mit s-bahn kleber
ich glaube die blätter sind sogar zu
viel
ich glaube ich dass so keines
erdbeertorte
[Musik]
die törtchen sind jetzt aufgetaut und
verzehr bereit und heute darf war da wo
ich bin war wenn du kommst also in das
video dann soll's team aus singen
[Musik]
traurigkeit ansonsten gibt's muttertag
so ne da spielt man nur man sich ja
warum bastelten backt ja ich beides
nicht kann habe ich dort sind
aber das kannst du mal nachmachen ist
echt ist es einfach wäre ich das hin ja
das kriegst du hin
ich probiere es mal okay ein bisschen
erdbeertörtchen natürlich auch von
erdrutschen
ich finde die konsistenz ist dieses
angaben ist immer so kohl
albert hatte auch die akut rausgeholt
von interessant seine quark erdberg
leben würde mich an irgendwas
ja tatsächlich oder erdbeereis städten
etwa in der stadt dem roten boden ich
glaube optisch wird es mir besser
gefallen wenn der boden schoko wer den
schotterboden nicht rot sondern dunkel
stimmt ja auch schön wer jetzt mich so
an gabel an löffel denke ich so jetzt
vielleicht besser gepasst aber ist nicht
schlimm
ihr könnt ja so wie ihr möchtet wir
haben ja photoshop schoko ja genau macht
ihr dann per boot und optimierten
einfach wir können also denken der
dunkle machen hab da noch so eine schoko
sahne schoko note noch mit drin aber so
ist eigentlich ganz cool lecker sind
auch vor allem schmerz leicht und es ist
wirklich einfach in der herstellung wenn
man eben die silikon form benutzt und
dann muss man es einfrieren lassen
einfach nur überwiesen
das war fertig so viel und ich finde die
sesam könne ja und ich freue mich
natürlich freut sich jeder
die mama und verteilen dann hat mich nur
eine torte zu sagen kann teilen und kam
noch dass schwiegermama eine gehen und
vielleicht auch der oma und tante
visualisiert timon die man mag und die
man kennt ja also probiert das rezept
gerne mal aus falls diese kleine
törtchen ist auf eure muttertags to back
liste schaffen dann postet gerne ein
foto markiert mich darauf kann ich mir
nämlich auch anschauen und ich finde
jetzt allen mama jetzt schon einmal
einen wunderschönen muttertag murat hat
auch meine muttertags torte gemacht dass
man es mit himbeeren
die war auch richtig cool geld ja 40
seine mittel für seine wohnt ja leider
nicht so gut mit
kaffee und fertig
[Musik]
[Applaus]